♪ ♪
>> Bret: GOOD EVENING, WELCOME
TO WASHINGTON, I AM BRET BAIER,
WE BRING THE TEXT MESSAGES THAT
YOU ARE NEVER SUPPOSED TO SEE.
SUGGESTING TWO FBI EMPLOYEES MAY
HAVE TRIED TO USE A PERSONAL
RELATIONSHIP WITH A FEDERAL
JUDGE, A FISA JUDGE TO INFLUENCE
THE INVESTIGATION INTO THE TRUMP
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
THIS COMES ON A DAY WHEN A
CAREER FBI EXECUTIVE COULD LOSE
HIS FULL GOVERNMENT PENSION
AFTER BEING ACCUSED OF ACTING ON
A SIMILAR BIAS AGAINST THE
PRESIDENT.
CHIEF INTELLIGENCE CORRESPONDENT
CATHERINE HERRIDGE IS HERE WITH
DETAILS PRETTY GOOD EVENING.
>> THANK YOU, IN LATE JULY 2016
AFTER THE CLINTON EMAIL CASE
CLOSED AND THE FBI OPEN THE
RUSSIAN INVESTIGATION, TEXT
MESSAGES INDICATE FBI AGENT
PETER STRZOK TALKED ABOUT HIS
FRIENDSHIP WITH THE FEDERAL
JUDGE WHO LATER HANDLED THE
PROSECUTION OF FORMER NATIONAL
SECURITY ADVISOR MIKE FLYNN.
INVESTIGATORS WORKING FOR THE
HOUSE REPUBLICANS REVIEWED THE
ORIGINAL DOCUMENTS AT THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND TOOK
NOTE, BECAUSE A COPY SENT TO
CONGRESS WERE HEAVILY REDACTED
WITH KEY DETAILS BLACKED OUT.
TEXTING ON THEIR WORK LOANS, THE
FBI LOVE OR SUGGEST SETTING UP A
COCKTAIL PARTY WITH BROOD ALL
CONCERTOS, WHO SITS ON THE
SURVEILLANCE COURT.
PAGE WRITES, JUDGE IS ON THE
FISC, DID YOU KNOW THAT,
APPOINTED TWO MONTHS AGO.
PETER STRZOK, I DID, I NEED TO
GET TOGETHER WITH HIM.
>> I CANNOT IMAGINE EITHER ONE
OF YOU WOULD TALK ABOUT ANYTHING
IN DETAIL MEANINGFUL ENOUGH FOR
RICK RUSSO ASKED MARK PETER
STRZOK, REALLY?
ANY ESPIONAGE BUYS A WARREN'S?
WHAT SHOULD HE DO?
AFTER TEXTING ABOUT AND ON
WANTED ISSUE, SUPER RIGOROUS
ABOUT ETHICS AND CONFLICT, AND
SUGGESTED A SOCIAL SETTING WITH
OTHERS WOULD PROBABLY BE BETTER
THAN A ONE-ON-ONE MEETING.
I'M SORRY, I'M GOING TO HAVE TO
INVITE YOU TO THE COCKTAIL
PARTY.
OF COURSE YOU WILL HAVE TO BE
THERE, COMING UP WITH SOME OTHER
WORK PEOPLE COVER FOR ACTION.
ONE MORE, A PERFECTLY FINE
DINNER PARTY.
IT'S NOT CLEAR FROM THE TEXT
MESSAGES WHETHER IT HAPPENED AND
THE FEDERAL JUDGE ATTENDED AFTER
NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER MIKE
FLYNN PLED GUILTY TO LYING TO
THE FBI IN DECEMBER, LESS THAN A
WEEK LATER CONTRERAS WAS REMOVED
WITHOUT EXPLANATION.
INVESTIGATORS QUESTION WHETHER
THERE IT WAS I CONNECTION TO
PETER STRZOK WHO CONDUCTED THE
INTERVIEW.
THEY KNEW THAT THE TEXT MESSAGES
UNDERCUT THE FBI'S LEADERSHIP
AND THE LONG-STANDING STRAIN
THAT THE BUREAU IS ABOUT
POLITICS.
>> HAS THE DISMISSAL OF
MR. JAMES COMEY INTERRUPTED,
STOPPED, OR NEGATIVELY IMPACTED
ANY OF THE WORK, ANY
INVESTIGATION OR ANY ONGOING
PROJECT OF THE FEDERAL BUREAU OF
INVESTIGATION?
>> THERE HAS BEEN NO EFFORT TO
IMPEDE OUR INVESTIGATION TODAY.
SIMPLY PUT, SIR, YOU CANNOT STOP
THE MEN AND WOMEN OF THE FBI
FROM DOING THE RIGHT THING,
PROTECTING THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND UPHOLDING THE CONSTITUTION.
>> A DECISION FROM THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL JEFF SESSIONS
ON THE FATE OF THE FORMER
DIRECTOR ANDREW McCABE YOU SAW
THERE, AND WHETHER HE WILL BE
FIRED FOR CAUSE IMPACTING HIS
PENSION IS EXPECTED AT ANY TIME.